Marketing divisions have been known to
come up with some off-the-wall ideas to
attract customers such as combining two
apparently unrelated and even
incompatible things
when the deeper indicate car testers
Sacha Kopp
describes the Jeep renegade as just such
a combination a pizza burger totally
American on the outside and old-world
Italian inside not the Ferrari or
Lamborghini kind of Italian but like its
close relative the Fiat 500x being built
in Melfi Italy doesn't mean cuts in
quality after all Fiat started building
cars in the early 20th century over 40
years before Jeep did
sascha confirms that the Fiat
engineering under the hood keeps its
promise the renegade doesn't have that
squishy American feel but the firm tight
European handling an advantage here on
German rules we are test driving the
2-liter 125 kilowatt diesel Jeep rates
the maximum speed at 196 km/h making it
stronger and faster than Fiats own
biggest diesel driven model
integrated into the design are many nods
to its progenitor the first Willie's
cheap from 1941 the radiator grille and
the many X shaped motifs intended to
recall the reserved gas canisters of the
originals
the jeep makes a boxier impression than
its Fiat brother almost like an outsized
toy car some sure worries that people
will think he himself is scarfed too
many pizza burgers but he reminds us
that it's still a Fiat 500x inside and
that means very little room he sees that
the front seatbacks do have space for
his knees so at least he can fit inside
but he imagines that on long distances
this can get uncomfortable the interior
makes a fairly rough and tough hard
plastic impression
it definitely can't be described as
elegant but it feels durable and
resilient
the very first Jeep was designed to be
rough and ready for military use and
remained in army service until the 1970s
now it's an indestructible collector's
item
as of Karina
Sasha hasn't acquired a taste for the
pizza burger but the Jeep renegade is
something else again at the very least
it's the lowest price option for future
Jeep owners a good three thousand euros
less than the original Fiat 500x at the
Fiat food fanatic